[Musik]
bismark erst ist brought you the munich
sehen was das mit juliana von roche zu
tun haben könnte ich würde auch vorlesen
wenn ich da hinkommen braucht jemand
anders oder gut so heute ist unser thema
juliana von deutsch und vielleicht ab
jetzt werde ich einfach sagen turin auf
deutsch denn sie ist engländer der
engländerin nichts wie ich übrigens ich
bin amerikaner immerhin ist es spannend
zu sehen dass wir schon im 14
jahrhundert und soll ein 14 14
jahrhundert nach christus paar englische
also engelberg viele social und
theologische werke haben die auf
englisch verfasst wurden
[Musik]
diese tradition der sogenannten
englischen mystik fängt schon im
vierzehnten jahrhundert an und wird
normalerweise als ein phänomen
beschrieben mit fünf hauptautoren wobei
es gibt andere werke die man dazu nehmen
könnte
die fünf autoren sind richard roy
gestorben 1949 1396 we camp die das ist
die späteste 1438 oder später und dann
die zwei texte die ich oder eine autorin
und einen text die ich heute beschlossen
werde thüringen von deutsch gestorbenen
nach 1416 und ein text namens cloud
wolke des unwissens ist ich manchmal
da merke ich gern dass irgendwelche
ideen oder titeln aus der geschichte was
wir auch gute heavy-metal-bands namen
werden zum also mein lieblingsbeispiel
ist das hat sogar mit dem problem des
bösen zu tun
in der antwort zum problem des bösen von
alben feininger kommt den auszug vor
und wenn ich eine heavy-metal-band
begründen würde würde ich das trans
world apart ihnen aber auch gut wäre
klar
oder geht es uns bis zum wissens hat
aber gar nichts mit heavy metal zu tun
sondern hell wie es das ist was ich will
diesen text heute ein bisschen
beschreiben damit ich dann ein bisschen
im hintergrund setzen kann und vor allem
wollte ich zeigen dass sie eine art
mystizismus hat die wir eben nicht in
zeitgenössischen texten und bedingt
finden sogar in texten die aus dem
gleichen menü kommt sogar texte die auch
auf englisch geschrieben werden
allgemein kann man natürlich sagen dass
all diese texte zu einem breiteren
phänomen gehören was wir schon bemerkt
haben
in der geschichte der mit philosophie
nämlich volkssprache gewerke wir haben
gesehen dass margarete foretz schrieb
auf französisch hildegard von bingen
steht eigentlich auf lateinisch aber da
kommt deutsch ab und zu rein aber
märkten von magdeburg schreibt auf
deutsch und hatte beschreibt auf
holländisch und wie wir nächste woche
sein werden hat zusagen auf italienisch
geschrieben natürlich wie ich jetzt
mehrmals gesagt habe es ist kein zufall
dass wir weibliche autorinnen und
volkswagen autoren finden weil sie eben
nichts in der schola sechs klassische
ausbildung latein erworben haben
also es heißt es war das für sie nichts
anderes übrig geblieben als in einer
sprache zu lesen aber dass man nicht
vergessen dass auch männliche autoren
die gleiche zeit
fußball die werke verfasst haben zum
beispiel diese zwei autoren die ich
gerade genannt habe wird wollen wort
halten und man geht davon aus dass das
der wolke des unwissens auch männlich
war vielleicht sogar ein priester bei am
ende des textes sagt der zum zudem dem
der text gewidmet ist sagt du hast
segnen von gott und von mir also man
könnte davon entnehmen dass er priester
war und deswegen männlich also nochmal
sollen wir nicht vorschnell denken okay
wir haben einen haufen weiblich autoren
und sie sind gegenüber gesetzt von den
männlichen hauptrollen das mittelalter
ist die manager auf latein als klassiker
die männer die die weibliche autorinnen
schreiben auf innsbruck sprache und sind
keinesfalls ticker es gibt nichts
klassische männer die auch auf druck
sprache geschrieben haben
allerdings muss man hinzufügen dass
rolle und helfen auch werke auf latein
verfasst haben
also es werden zum beispiel theorien
keine werke auf latein verfasst hat was
können wir dann also das erst kommen wir
mehr vielleicht ist es vielleicht ein
bisschen spekulativ aber
wenn wir jetzt nachdenken warum solche
autoren auf englisch schreiben oder in
anderen sprachen
das erste was einfällt ist natürlich um
ein breiteres oder vielleicht einfach
handel das publikum zu erreichen
und da scheint hier der fall zu sein
alle diese all die werke dieser autoren
schlechtes auto mit ausnahme von michael
kempf sind gibt es so gedacht dass sie
für andere monastisch lebende christen
gedacht sind und vor allem für ein
nachtreten weil ich glaube dass das
deutsche wort bereits auf englisch also
das heißt nur us kritiker die von der
von der stadt zum beispiel leben und
allein in armut freiwillige armut sogar
das und wenn man es sich vorstellt denkt
man vielleicht sofort an die spätantike
wo wir verschiedene us kritiker haben
zum beispiel antonius der große die so
heldenhaft als kritisch gelebt haben zum
beispiel ohne essen wochenlang wo das
sitzen auf einer säule monaten lang
essen ist schlagen sich mit der peitsche
bla bla bla bla bla und das ist ein
bisschen schwer mit der tatsache zu
vereinigen dass sie auch bücher
geschrieben haben
also man nicht vergessen bücher sind im
mittelalter in der antike wirklichen
luxusobjekte das ist als ob eine
skeptiker der herkommt und sagt ja ich
bin als skeptiker ich gebe in
freiwilligen armut und er ist mein sport
auto
aber dass man vorsichtig sein zum
beispiel antonius war eigentlich der der
held von von geschichten die von anderen
geschrieben würden über ihn ein
interessantes beispiel des hieronymus
ein sehr wichtiger kirchenvater der
tatsächlich lange große im header die
bücher geschrieben hat und übersetzungen
aus dem griechischen und für ihn war es
wirklich problematisch wie konnte er wie
ein gelehrter leben und gleichzeitig als
es geht und ich habe irgendwo in einem
buch wie wir ihn gelesen in seiner höhle
war es anscheinend ziemlich eng weil
eine große bibliothek hatte ist man kann
so was erklären dass manche von diesen
asketen auch schreiber hatten die um die
bücher zu kopieren also irgendwie
komisch aber das soll man nicht
vergessen dass viele von diesen asketen
auch reich waren also die waage bleibt
und sind frei mit freiwillig an geworden
und deswegen wenn sie irgendwas behalten
wollten zb diener oder scheibe dann das
hatten oder stoff um bücher zu verfassen
das hatten sie leisten können im
allgemeinen kann man sagen dass dieses
asketisch muss übrigens rassismus ist
als casey meine ich es wirklich sehr
wichtig als thema für juliana und vor
allem für christine wie wir nächste
woche sehen werden also deswegen wollte
ich das ein bisschen betonen als käse
ist vielleicht nicht das was als
philosophisches thema zuerst auffallen
würde das klingt mehr wie vielleicht ein
theologisches thema oder halt hat gar
nichts mit uns zu tun vielleicht aber
das ist wirklich falsch als käse in der
christlichen antike kommt mehr oder
weniger unmittelbar
der philosophischen tradition und das
aus mehreren gründen erstens muss man
nicht vergessen dass heimische
philosophen auch ästhetisch gerät haben
sehr oft vor allem muss man an die
zyniker denken zum beispiel georgien ist
der zyniker der in einem weinfass links
wurde auch historiker waren die
flugstrecke waren anscheinend immer für
askese bereits uns sogar später der
historiker auch wenn sie nicht am leben
bestehen darauf dass sie an dass sie
bereit wären arm zu leben zum beispiel
marcus caelius ist also er ist sehr weit
weg von arm er ist der kaiser des
römischen reiches aber er ist sagt er
wir wussten ja dass ich mein ich bin
zwar der reichste mann der welt aber ich
wäre als armer mann haupt glücklich sehr
günstig also erstens das also diese
diese verbindung zwischen philosophie in
askese oder vielleicht zwischen
intellektuelles leben und das geht sehr
weit zurück in die heimische it services
tradition hessen dass ein zweites in der
spätantike ist das sehr eng mit
philosophischen ideen verbunden
vor allem weil die sie immer eine
begründung oder erklärung für diese
ästhetische lebenspraxis dadurch
anbieten dass sie auf die platonische
theorie der seele hinweisen
das hatten wir schon wir haben anfang
des semesters wir haben eine seele die
sozusagen aufgegliedert ist in drei
teilen aber da kann man einfache von
zwei teilflächen vernunft würde
intellekt geist ist ein ist ein teil und
dann die unsere seele die von platon
zwei gegliedert würde und die untere
zelle ist irgendwie fest an körper
verbunden
also das heißt dass man umzügen es sogar
bei platon und eigentlich zu leben zu
leben muss man vernunft
was man der 50 kontrolle über die unsere
seele und den körper geben und die
unsere seele anscheinend schwach genug
machen dass die unsere serie die obere
saale nicht daran hindert kunst zu leben
und dann natürlich schlägt platon nicht
vor dass man rausgehen kann soll in die
wüste nichts essen oder sowas
also er erschlägt nicht vor dass man
ganz asketisch lebt aber dieser schluss
würde oft gezogen in der platonischen
situation zum beispiel profi aus der
schule des platins der begründer des
zionismus profitiert schreibt ein werk
über die frage ob man tiere fleisch
essen soll
und dann sagt er nein das begründet
dadurch dass tiere mit uns viele
gemeinsamkeiten haben es vielleicht sind
sogar vernünftig haben vielleicht sogar
sprache also er sagt vielleicht sprechen
sie und wir verstehen die einfach nicht
aber seine hauptbegründung ist das
fleisch gut schmeckt das heißt wir
sollen fleisch vermeiden weil lust und
freude an fleisch essen eine ablenkung
ist weg von dem spirituellen leben und
lebende der vernunft und ist wie er sagt
ein nagel ein nagel die uns mit dem
körper befestigt wir sind natürlich die
serie und der körper ist uns fremd
deswegen hat man schon in der spätantike
platonisch muss eine sehr starke neigung
in manchen autoren zur askese und das
wird übernommen von christen und die
geben eigentlich die gleiche natürlich
in natürlich könnte man zum beispiel
versuchen als käse durch biblische texte
zu unterstützen das machen sie auch
aber die hauptbegründung die man unter
diesen asketische natur findet er ist
eben dass sie den körper schwächen
wollen und die unsere seele sprechen
wollen das gilt dann auch für
mittelalterliche askese sie haben mehr
oder wenn du die gleiche ansichten über
den körper die seele ist das was mit uns
mit gott verbindet der körper und
körperliche liste sind die sachen die
uns weg von gott drehen
und deswegen soll man möglichst
asketisch leben denn es geht dann ist
die frage nur wie weit sondern gehen und
das war sehr sehr umstritten
zum beispiel gibt es eine riesige streit
im zweiten jahrhundert und dann noch im
14 jahrhundert immer noch es gibt
eigentlich eine rege sich zweitligist
über armut und monastischen ordnen und
wie die franziskaner und dominikaner
weil da muss man nicht vergessen die
kirche in dieser zeit ist sehr sehr
reich hat große anteil des landes in
jedem mittal welchem land die der papst
ist nicht wie ein könig sein hof ist wie
ein königlicher hof bitte
genau da ist natürlich wird das von dem
jetzigen papst sogar thematisiert ja ok
aber konzentrieren wir uns damals die
dann kam kommen diese bettler ordnen
dominikaner franziska unter anderem und
sagen okay wir sind auch religiöse
vorbilder und wir leben absichtlich bar
wir besitzen sogar gar nichts die hatten
die theorie dass alles was sie als
besitz hatten nur ausgeliehen würden von
der kirche und schließlich gehört das
als dem papst sogar das essen was sie
konsumieren gehört ihnen nichts sondern
der kirche sie leihen das aus kritiker
haben natürlich gesagt wie kannst du
essen konstruieren was ausgeliehen ist
weil das dann kannst du das nicht
zugeben aber aber gebäude bücher solche
sachen die haben immer fest behauptet
selbst als diese ordnung ganz reich
geworden sind das ist natürlich des
fingers anfang mit franziskus der
wirklich angelegt hat aber bis ende des
zweiten jahrhunderts die ordnen wirklich
sehr reich aber das war in zu sagen egal
weil sie immer fest behauptet haben dass
gehört uns nicht wir haben das war diese
gebäude inmitten in paris und so weiter
und haben die lehrstühle in paris 1
christin universität aber wir sind immer
noch an
und das war sehr sehr umstritten auch
institutionell innerhalb der kirche und
noch mehr umstritten war die frage was
man mit diesen optimistischen autoren
machen soll
die super asketisch gelebt haben also
die oft an krankheiten oder verhungern
dann gestorben sind das werden wir
nächste woche noch mal mit christine
sehen und diese frage also wie man
sozusagen mit dem körper umgehen soll
ist sehr wichtig für frauen mystic in
mittelalter und nochmals vorbild dafür
ist christine sein wie wir sein werden
juliana wird oft auch in diesem
zusammenhang erwähnt ich denke aber dass
sie nicht als radikaler askese gesehen
werden soll
sonst also ist es nicht so als radikal
wie christine immerhin hat sie wie ein
korrekt gelebt das war auch wie in der
spätantike war das ist waren möglich wie
an krebs leben also in einer zelle kein
haus zu besitzen nichts zu besitzen aber
trotzdem diener zu haben und wirst du
sogar dass reiche leute in englands dann
immer reichtum an krediten geerbt haben
erklärt lassen haben damit sie dann
weiter leben so leben konnten
und manchmal haben sie relativ viel geld
in diese weise gekommen bekommen
theoretisch leben sie als sehr sehr an
und das betrifft
auf jeden fall juni um 9 und
wahrscheinlich auch den autor der wolke
des unwissens und auch seien seinen
gewünschten laser es ist eigentlich ein
wie so oft ist es in mit lustig ist der
text ein brief und es an einem
bestimmten einer an einer bestimmten
person gewidmet der das lesen soll
wie gesagt ist der autor anscheinend
vielleicht sogar ein priester priester
oder mindestens vielleicht älter und
weiser als der der das buch lesen soll
der der leser
oder gezielte leser ist anscheinend ein
junger religiöser mann der aus dem buch
lernen soll wie er gott wichtig lieben
sollte die wenn man bücher über die
geschichte der mitte also in flüsse viel
liest wie ich mich ob geklagt habe
kommen frauen sehr wenig vor
das betrifft auch julian liliana ist
betrifft nichts so sehr dass die wolke
des unwissens und man kennt sie sich
fragen ok warum warum darf diese zum
beispiel als ich dort student war mit
und mich mit meiner philosophie verfasst
habe habe ich was man über die worte des
unwissens gelernt aber nichts über
julien von deutsch und man kann sie sich
fragen warum also zwei mystische werke
ähnliche ansichten warum ist ein gehört
ein buch zur geschichte der philosophie
und das andere buch nichts antwort
dieses prada waren neu in würde von
philosophischen quellen beeinflusst vor
allem von dem 23
dionysius also was wir hier haben ist
eine eine kombination zu sagt zusammen
aus mit einer mystischen strömung die
auch in diesen anderen englischen texten
vorkommt und eine eher philosophische
ordnung die ursprünglich mit pearl de
news anfängt und dann in diesem werk
mündet wenn sie zuerst merkst du der
mystischen strohmann haben was finden
wir bei diesen anbietern englischen
autoren vor der wolke des unwissens wie
gesagt sind die hauptautoren hier zwei
männer welche rolle wohl weiter halten
und sie was sehr interessant ist für uns
vor allem ist dass sie ratgeber für
frauen geschrieben haben also nicht nur
männer so ein auszug weg für frauen und
das hängt wahrscheinlich damit zusammen
dass mit der tatsache dass sie auf
englisch geschrieben weil sie wussten
wenn ich frauen erreichen will oder
frauenhaus bilden im religiösen leben
will dann muss ich auf englisch
schreiben weil sie keinen dateien
besitzen beherrschen und dass das sind
wirklich also wenn ich sage dass das
diese bücher ratgeber sind dass das
wirklich die arme der behörden also das
sind keine eigentlich keine
philosophische werke wie andere werke
die wir betrachtet haben kommen
philosophische ideen manchmal rein also
jetzt stufen der vollkommenheit und
solche sachen aber die aber die
hauptthese die sie vertreten ist dass
man den eigenen selbst bei niedrigen
soll und besser gott zu leben also zum
beispiel ein typisches zitat ist dass
das die menschheit nichts ist wenn kein
hessen nord und das ist das wird
ziemlich heldenhaft beschrieben also es
heißt sie beschreiben ein leben wo man
wirklich alles an korrekt oder das ist
ganz gerne als monastischen ganz
asketisch lebt es ist nichts zu sagen
rat für den normalen christ das rad für
der über quest deswegen spricht man
manchmal in der sekundären server von
einem gewissen spiritualität und es ist
wirklich elitär aber nichts
sozioökonomisch elitär sondern
spiritualität
es ist für die die ganz kleine
minderheit der burg der menschheit die
wirklich gott erreichen kann und will
übrigens an die meine frau ist deutsch
oder das bayerisch
die niederbayerische sie sie haben
vielleicht gemerkt hoffentlich gemerkt
merkt das wenn ich spreche dass in
deutschland sind aber in den harz nicht
hoffentlich und das ist eben hier weil
sie das immer überfüllt weil sie hat
heute früh gesehen dass ich stand nicht
gab was über gott erreichen geschrieben
und ich habe gott erriechen geschrieben
und das hat sie sehr lustige von auf
jeden fall der einzige weg gott zu
erreichen oder erreichen ist ist nichts
durch philosophie wurde theologie
sondern durch liebe wie soll man ihn
dort liebe erreichen habe sich dadurch
dass man nichts anderes liegt also mann
soll den eigenen körper auch die die
geschaffene welt selbst erniedrigen oder
als nichts halten im vergleich zu gott
dass damit man ihn näher kommt und wenn
man das also manchmal in diesen texten
wird das alles mystische erfahrung
beschrieben
okay das bringt uns zum diesem buch klar
oder waren und all diese themen die ich
gerade beschrieben habe sind hier
vorhanden
allerdings wird sap tiefe philosophische
saison ausgedrückt und waren wirklich
mit einer pistole die verbunden
oder vielleicht praktische theologie
könnte man sagen fängt damit an und das
ist die passage wo wovon wir den titel
haben fängt damit an dass er sagt wenn
wir versuchen trotz super riechen dann
fangen wir in einem in einer wolke des
unwissens an
also wir bescheid ist auch als als
finsternis zu befinden uns in einer
finsternis und haben keinen zugang zu
gott was wollen wir das machen
jetzt würde thomas von aquin zb sagen
kein problem
gott hat die welt geschaffen und wir
können gott durch die geschaffene welt
irgendwie begreifen zum beispiel wir
können ihn als ursache der welt
begreifen
und das ist eben nichts das ist sogar
das gegenteil gegenteil von dem was
dieser autor sagt diese haut vor sagt um
gott besser zu verstehen und verstehen
es wahrscheinlich hier das falsche wort
soll man die soll man wie er sagt eine
andere wolke schaffen das ist die wolke
des vergessens mann soll diese welt
vergessen damit gar nichts bleibt
und da schwebt man einfach in einer
wolke von nichts und da versteht man
überhaupt nichts weder welt noch gott
aber das ist das ist trotzdem
fortschritte weil der richtige weg gott
zu begreifen nicht durch wissen oder
vernunft oder sonst was kommt sondern
durch
also wenn man das die welt vergisst ist
man offen für gott und man empfindet nur
nur liebe für gott und dann gibt er zu
dass es drei arten dieser vorgang dieser
kontemplativen dieses kontemplativen
leben es gibt und die ordnet er
dreistufig nach es gibt zwei arten des
aktiven lebens und zwei arten des
kontemplativen lebens die höhe des
höhere aktives leben ist gleich mit dem
niedrigeren kontemplativen leben also
etwas schnell abschreiben
[Musik]
also 123 ist es klar dass niedrige
aktives leben ist das nicht die
niedrigste variante dann gibt es die
zweite wahl das ist die dass höhere
aktives leben und das niedrige
kontemplatives leben und dann gibt es
gibt es das kontemplatives leben das
kontemplative leben ist dass das hoch
die dieses das höre ist natürlich das
was er vorschlagen werde und beschreiben
will was sind diese zwei hier also die
das untere leben ist das leben der
tugend und das erinnert sehr an
margareta dass wir die last die letzte
woche gesehen haben
also wenn man einfach unter anderen
menschen freiwillig und tugendhaft zum
beispiel geld spendet oder laden voll
ist und so weiter
dass es zwar gut und ist wirklich ob es
wirklich ein versuch und ein ehrlicher
versuch mit gott vereint zu sein
aber das kann man nur so weit bringen
das zweite ist immer noch aktiv oder
sozusagen mit praktische maßnahmen ist
auszuführen
aber es auch schon kontemplativ und die
idee hier ist dass man aktiv an
irgendwelche religiöse symbole denkt zum
beispiel das leiden jesus christus
oder sind die oder sünde was sünde
bedeutet solche sachen
also man soll
vielleicht auch asketisch leben und dass
es haargenau eine beschreibung von dem
was julian am 8 wir sehen werden
juliana hatte diese offenbarungen wo es
sind zum beispiel das blut jesus
christus gesehen hat und sie hat
nachgedacht was bedeutet dass und immer
wieder überlegt was die bedeutung dieser
visionen sein könnte und also macht man
könnte fast denken dass der autor des
klarnamens juliana gelesen hätte früher
reagiert da darf man sagt ja zwar gute
sogar besser als normal christliches
tugendhaftes leben aber nichts die
höchste stufe die höchste stufe ist
dieses nichts also dieses begreifen das
nicht begreifen von gar nichts wo man
ohne verstand verständnis und ohne
intellektuelle aktivität einfach offen
für gott ist und effektiv flights
richtung gott offen ist statt ihn aktiv
zu begreifen
und er sagt auch übrigens dass diese
zweite stufe
problematisch ist denn diese dieses in
sich kern gefährlich sein kann weil das
ist zwar eine eine möglichkeit wie man
offen für einfluss von gott von der
seite gott sein könnte dass es zwar gut
aber es ist auch gefährlich weil da ist
man offen für einflüsse von bösen wesen
zum beispiel dämonen oder satan und als
der geschichte spielt er sogar wie man
den unterschied erkennen kann und das
ist eine sehr lustige passage wie man
das nichts der will nicht lustig sein
aber er sagt er habe von micro vans gibt
es dieses wort nec romantiker oder sowas
ok auf jeden fall von diesen man diese
leute hat er erfahren dass satan immer
in form eines menschen erscheint der nur
ein nasenloch hat weil normale menschen
zwei nasenlöcher haben und das habe sie
das ist symbolisch für unsere fähigkeit
gut von böse zu unterscheiden
und da eine böse ist hat er nur einen
hasen noch was ganz ganz nett also falls
sie irgendwann einen traum haben wo
jemand einen blasen wirkt dann wissen
sie weglaufen
auf jeden fall also diese idee visionen
sind gefährlich und nichts tut nichts
total ich weil vielleicht sind sie böse
einflüsse
das ist sehr weit verbreitet in sogar in
der interimistischen literatur und
natürlich als diese leute wie zum
beispiel theorien als sie sieben oder
damals hätte gar möchten und so weiter
als sie sich vorgestellt haben und
gesagt nun behauptet haben dass sie
botschaft von gott gehört haben
am anderes gesagt dass du sicher ist
dass wirklich also was sollen wir
darüber denken und die sind ja sehr
nervös geworden
ok also dass das bringt uns übrigens an
ich wollte auch erwähnen nur weil es
interessantes und dass das wird man ihn
vielleicht noch mal ein interview sowie
wurde in die religion
dann erinnern man also die zu der frage
was man tun soll
in diesem hat diesem hoch höheren
kontemplativen leben
schlägt er vor staatsgelder nachzudenken
zum beispiel leidende christus soll man
nur wörter nehmen einzelne wörter am
besten wollte mit einem mit einer selbe
zum beispiel auf englisch garde oder
sein und immer wieder sagen wie in der
indischen tradition ist interessant ist
eine erhalten mehr die taten meditation
also man könnte sagen das ist sozusagen
bildlich und sehr körperlich und konkret
und das ist sehr abstrakt und meditativ
und es interessant dass das der in der
geschichte der bedeutenden für das wir
auch vorkommt wie gesagt ist das alles
mit dem namen zweier genesius verbunden
ob sie alle wissen wer das war das ist
ein denker aus der spätantike der neue
platonische ideen übernommen hatte vor
allem aus pop los ein sehr sehr
überzeugt heimische denker und er hat
ideen ausfloss übernommen und sie in
christliche ideen verwandelt und
beschreibt sich als dionysios 1 1 figur
der auch in der bibel vorkommt und
anwesend war als paulus dann gepredigt
hatte und die mit deutliche leserschaft
waren überzeugt dass das wirklich dieser
apostolische figur ist der tatsächlich
obwohl der autor tatsächlich vier von
fünf jahrhunderte später und hitze und
die daten er war er war an ein heiliger
der sogar jesus gesehen hatte und
deswegen haben sie war eine hauptquelle
für neue platonische ideen durch mittel
hat viel mit deutliche zeit thomas vanek
wie zum beispiel schreibt 1 kommentar so
ein so sein hauptwerk der haut dort
wollte des unwissens ist wahrscheinlich
der gleiche der ein kleineres werk von
tns ilres von lateinischen ins englische
übersetzt hatte war das kommt in der
gleichen handschrift vor
interessant genug hintergrund hat jemand
fragen über diesen hintergrund bevor ich
die lianen gespräche ja
[Musik]
es gibt so von dem was ich gelesen habe
gibt es keine belege dass sie auch
keinen übrigens auch kein beleg dass der
autor des der wolke des unwissens
juliana gelesen hatte also
wahrscheinlich sind die umhänge und die
sind auch ungefähr gleich seite vorbei
also diesen nicht ganz klar waren die
wolke des universums geschrieben würde
wahrscheinlich in den frühen 12 90
manche glauben sogar sogar sogar
übrigens das porto helton der autor sei
also dass nichts jetzt die verbreitete
meinung jetzt denkt man das einfach ein
anonymer autor syrien schrieb ihre shows
ungefähr in dieser zeit also um die
wände von 14 zu fünfzehnten jahrhundert
sie ist übrigens später als christine
habe ich dachte dass julien besser so
diese reihenfolge passt was wir schon
gesehen haben also märkte so ein halbes
und dann margarita und dungeon das hat
den wie wir sein werden und christina
ist ein bisschen ein handel das phänomen
hat vielmehr mit askese sie tun made
weniger lästig andere fragen
juliana von deutsch die unsere
hauptquelle für ihr leben ist ihr buch
die chance oder offenbarungen der
göttlichen liebe und wie immer gibt es
ein auszug aus ihrem werk auf der
website dieses mal sogar auf deutsch
wenn sie das lesen wollen
also sie erklärt uns dass sie zuerst was
interessantes sagen über ihr leben dass
wir nicht aus dem buch entnehmen können
als sie alt war im 214 116 hat sie
begegnet beziehungsweise metal camp zu
mir gekommen und hat praktisch nach rat
gefragt deutsche camp ist eigentlich
nicht so nicht so wichtig vielleicht für
die richter der philosophie aber super
interessant als person
es gab sogar vor ein paar wochen in der
radiosendung von der bbc
die heißt in altheim und die hatten eine
ganze folge
das ist deshalb das passt also das kann
man kostenlos im internet ein
unglaublich eine unglaubliche frau die
durch ganz europa gereist ist und sogar
nach jerusalem zurück gekommen weil die
andere pilger die mit ihr unterwegs
waren haben sie gehasst
ich weiß es ist so auch ziemlich war und
also ich habe den eindruck sie war
wirklich furchtbar aber erwähnen fall
dann später ist sie dann zu julien
gekommen und sie hat über sie berichtet
und gesagt wie heilig sie war und wie
hilfreich es ist schon interessant dass
zwei berühmte frauen dann zusammenkommen
diese anekdote ok auf jeden fall haben
das hauptwerk für julian ist ihr buch
diese offenbarung und das entsteht aus
einer erfahrung die sie im mai 1373
gehabt hatte sie erklärt und das sie
dass sie gibt gebetet hat um leiden zu
bekommen was sie besser verstehen
erlauben würde das leiden christi zu
also zu verstehen oder sogar zu erleben
so leiden wie jesus christus das war ihr
wunsch und gottes gnädig und hat eine
furchtbare krankheit geschäfts und sieht
im sterben im bett stirbt dann am ende
doch nichts sie wird wunder wunderbarer
von der nicht geheilt vielleicht drei
tage und werden sie schwitzend und mit
fieber im bett liegt sieht sie 610
visionen oder offenbarungen zum beispiel
sie sieht den teufel der welt nicht wie
viele nasenlöcher er hat aber das und
das kommt ganz am ende
am anfang sieht sie vor allem symbole
des leidens christus wie man fast
erwarten würde weil es war ihr wunsch
haben zum beispiel die die dornen die er
auf dem kopf hatte oder blut aus einem
gesicht und das beschreibt das alles
beschreibt sie sehr sehr konkret und
sehr körperlich auch mit tafeln sind es
gibt eine wunderbare passage wo es zeigt
dass die die bluttropfen schauen aus wie
wie die schuppen an einer fisch an einem
fisch weil sie so rinnen sind und fallen
wie wasser vom dach vom hausdach es ist
wirklich sehr sehr politisch fast könnte
man sagen
und am anfang ist das ist alles was sie
sozusagen bekommt also sie bekommt keine
das keine erklärung der offenbarungen
und dass es mit helga gar zu vergleichen
weil da sollen wir uns das sollen wir
zurückdenken an helligkeit hildegard
beschreibt diese versionen und dann sagt
sie
gott hat mir diese visionen geschickt
und auch so sagen die einen schlüssel
sie die versionen zu verstehen
ja also alles was sie schreibt ist
botschaft von gott
julian hat diese diesen vorteil nicht
dass sie bekommt die offenbarungen und
weiß hat keine ahnung was sie was die
bedeutung davon sein sollte und deswegen
sagt und das bereut sie sehr in dem buch
das sie das zuerst auch sie also auch so
als auch gefürchtet dass das bereits
deutliche einflüsse sein könnten könnten
am ersten stars ein zweites sich als sie
sich einfach nichts vorher zum beispiel
einen priester zu sagen was sie erlebt
hatte für uns zu fragen was die
bedeutung sein könnte und deswegen heißt
sie wunderlich geheilt wird sagt sie
habe als ich krank war hatte ich
tobsucht also ich war ist sie sagt und
dann hat sie trotzdem ein kurzes buch
verfasst wo sie die visionen dann
beschreibt das ist die kurze fassung und
hier uns schon jetzt hier fängt sie an
zu erklären was wir jetzt hat sie
natürlich schon hat sie doch nachgedacht
in gedanken ein dass das es doch von
gott gekommen gekommen nicht den teufel
aber sowas könnte die bedeutung seien
sie fängt anders zu erklären und dann
betrachtet sogar die fusion die frage ob
sie genügend autorität hat die ihre
eigene visionen selbst auszulegen
sie schreit immer zu meinem verständnis
standing heißt diese vision so und sehr
interessant in dieser fassung des buches
hat sie eine passage wo sie wo sie ihn
wie erwartet dass jemand sagen wird du
als frau hasst nichts keine recht diese
offenbarungen so auszulegen und ich
wollte vorlesen was sie zu dieser diesem
vorwurf schreibt das ist eine sehr
schöne passage für unser hauptthema der
vorlesung
das werde ich auf englisch vorlesen aber
langsam
also schnell die deutsche übersetzung
improvisiert du sollst nicht denken dass
ich lehrerin wenn das war nie meine
absicht denn ich bin nur eine frau und
wissen und schwach ich weiß aber dass
das was ich zu sagen habe
durch die offenbarung dessen der der
wirkliche test ganz natürlich weil ich
frau bin sollte ich da sollte schweigen
und nicht über das das gut sein also
gartners gut dass gute gottes erzählt
obwohl ich damals gesehen habe dass
seine will auch dort auch so ist dass
ich das erzählen sollte also sie hat
sozusagen erlaubnis von gott oder
ermunterung
gottes ihre geschichte zu erzählen und
auch zu erkennen was die visionen
bedeuten
das sollten wir wirklich vielleicht
starten kurz staunen das ist zum
beispiel nichts zu einem priester geben
sagt hier sind meine offenbarungen
kannst du die erkennen weil du bist
ausgebildet du bist ein mann was auch
immer nein sie sagt ich bin frau ich bin
zwar zwar nur frau schwach und unwissen
blablabla war nicht an der uni ist aber
ich kann sie kann meine eigene visionen
selber erklären und das ich behaupte
dass gott das soll wollte das ist
sozusagen jede eine vorstellung
interessanterweise vertiefte diese
passage in der späteren längeren fassung
weg sie die die kürzere fassung taucht
mehr oder weniger vollständig in der
längeren fassung auf manche passagen
fallen weg und da ist eine passage die
wegfällt sind ist interessant ihr habt
keine erklärung dafür in der natur
gesehen
auf jeden fall kann normalerweise wird
es behauptet dass diese kürzere fassung
sozusagen sehr unmittelbar nach der
visionen geschrieben würde also
vielleicht innerhalb ein paar jahren
aber es gibt auch versuche es zu zeigen
dass selbst die kurze fassung über eine
legende zeit geschrieben würde so oder
so würde die längere fassung über eine
sehr lange zeit über jahrzehnten
geschrieben nachgedacht verbessert und
also dass die fassung die wir haben ist
wirklich ein sehr fortgeschrittene
sportliche das werk voll mit
theologischen ansichten und ideen also
ist wirklich sehr interessant waren für
mich ist das mit margaritas buch das
interessanteste buch
von einer lenkerin des mittelalters
wahrscheinlich wobei vielleicht wir
müssen doch sehen was christine ist
anzubieten hat aber es ist wirklich ein
sehr interessantes buch ja wie
also nein aber das kommt in die dienste
der der zitat ja das problem ist dass
die übersetzungen die man kann sind
immer von der natürlich von der längeren
fassung
das habe ich aus einem buch über
theorien zitiert und wenn sie wollen
kann ich ihnen die passage schicken
ich glaube das ist von einem von einer
jemand die heiß becker also das ist die
schriftsteller also wenn sie hin dass es
auch hier in der bibliothek oder
vielleicht hat sich das als der stabi
aber auf jeden fall es gibt ein buch
über theorien england das heißt von
windhuk von vision blog von becker
sie erwähnte dieser stelle auf jeden
fall
wie gesagt die dieses buch ist so
interessant meinen divisionen sind zwar
sehr beeindruckend und sehr poetisch wir
sehr kritisch dargestellt
aber was für uns sehr interessant ist
ist die theologische inhalt des buches
und das hat vor allem mit einer
behauptung zu tun die sie in einer
vision erlebt übrigens schon sein kann
ist nicht nur so dass sie dass sie
bilder sieht also zum beispiel blutende
christus sie bekommt auch auditiv
botschaft von gott also gut mit ihr und
sagte rätselhafte dinge die sie dann
entschlossen muss und ein beispiel ist
super super grund müssen englisch wagen
welt ist sehr berühmt und das ist
also alles wird gut sein können dass
meine arbeit gleicht also die die
vollständige passage ist er sagt zu ihr
picknick offen
also alles wird gut
also ich kann alles gut machen ich werde
alles gut machen ich will alles gut
machen du wirst selber sehen dass sich
das also paul manthey fwg die art denkt
wird gut sein und diese das ist
sozusagen ein radikales optimismus wie
weit würden wahrscheinlich sagen was sie
hat als denkerin aber sie würde
behaupten das würde hier einfach gesagt
von gott also die frage für sie ist
[Musik]
dieser strom ausgegangen
ich rede einfach laut wenn sie mich alle
hören hinten also will das sagen okay
dieses radikal ist optimismus ist
sozusagen ihr kennzeichen haushalt ohne
sie würde ich sagen nein diese radikale
tourismus optimismus ist kein zeichen
gottes also das hat er mir offen oder
offenbart und ich versuche jetzt das zu
verstehen und sofort sehen wir dass wir
hier sehr nah an einem zentralen problem
der philosophie sind vor allem flüsse
wie der region nämlich das so genannte
problem des bösen
deswegen ist das auf dem whiteboard
also dass das problem des bösen ist sehr
groß das problem wie es sein kann dass
das böse existiert
obwohl gott existiert gott ist das
beschreibe ich sehr grob und dann werde
ich sehr hoffe ich sehr rigoros
beschreiben also das problem ist gottes
allwissend allmächtig und und alt gut
englisch sagt man immer haben die
buchungen sunny power from nations also
das heißt dass er es kann nicht sein
dass das böse ihm entgeht also er weiß
dass das böse vorkommt er könnte was
darüber machen natürlich weil er
allmächtig ist er kann alles machen und
er würde das böse abschaffen oder
eliminieren wenn er könnte
und natürlich weil er gut ist also hat
zusammen die mittel die motivation und
das wissen das böse ist zu entfernen
aber problem löse das böse existiert
also sachen passieren die die schlecht
sind oder die die böse sind und gott tut
gar nichts
das zu handeln warum und das ist
wahrscheinlich der grund würde der der
philosophische grund den man am
häufigsten anbietet um die existenz
gottes zu vereinen natürlich dass andere
argumente gegen gott zum beispiel wenn
man eher einen puristischen technologie
hat würde man vielleicht sagen dass man
gott durch wahrnehmung nicht begreifen
kann und deswegen haben könnten wir
keinen grund haben an gott zu glauben
aber dass das würde er in agnostizismus
führen
da könnte man höchstens sagen okay ich
habe keine belege für oder gegen gott
das ist wirklich ein grund die existenz
gottes zu verneinen
das ist ein sehr bekanntes problem als
sehr häufig in der philosophie der
religion diskutiert und ich wollte was
zum modernen problem sagen weil ich
immer denke das ist sehr verlockend ist
mittelalterliche und ein tiger theologen
und philosophen falsch zu verstehen wenn
sie sich mit diesem problem
auseinandersetzen denn es gibt mehrere
probleme hier die und so ist sozusagen
getan unterdeckung von einem problem
leben und das problem was sie hatten ist
nicht unser jetziges problem
meiner meinung nach war jetziges problem
ist mehr oder weniger wie würde wie kann
gott das erlauben
was hat er sehr faul ist jedoch nicht
gut also was also irgendwie muss also
irgendwas ist schief gegangen
entweder ist ja nicht allmächtig er kann
das böse doch nicht verändern oder es
nicht alle wissen dass er weiß nicht
dass das böse vorkommt oder es nicht gut
ja und das ist mehr oder weniger das
logische problem des bösen das hier
heißt logisches problem weil dieses
problem immer als logische widerspruch
dargestellt wird also manchmal sagt man
die feststellung dass gott existiert
schlicht nicht kompatibel mit der
feststellung dass das böse existiert
also entweder oder
und das böse existiert deswegen
existiert gott nicht positiv kann man
das als argument so anbieten
gott und hier stehen wir immer gott als
allmächtig all westens und almut gott
würde das böse nicht erlauben
natürlich kann man hier unter presse
geben zum beispiel
ein allmächtiges wesen wird alles machen
um sachen kann alles machen so das böse
zu hindern
ein gutes wesen würde das böse immer
eliminieren wollen wenn er könnte und so
weiter aber sie verstehen schon woher
wer diese prämisse kriegen zweite
prämisse böse existiert das böse
existiert schluss gott existiert nichts
und das ist wahrscheinlich das erste was
einfällt wenn wir über das problem des
bösen denken also die die behauptung
hier
wenn wir das ein bisschen umdrehen
vielleicht ist dass es schlicht
unmöglich ist das gott existieren könnte
angesichts der tatsache dass das dass
das böse existiert
ok also wir können das einfach
ausschließen
zum beispiel wenn jemand sagt wenn ihr
wenn jemand dieses argument gibt müsste
dazu müsste er denken dass es nicht die
geringste möglichkeit besteht dass gott
existiert also das ist wirklich also das
ist wirklich wahrscheinlichkeit nur dass
gott existiert wenn wenn wir deswegen
zeigen könnten
okay hier ist ein weg zu zeigen dass
gott wahrscheinlich nicht existiert aber
vielleicht doch das würde das logische
problem besiegen war das ist die
behauptung hier ist das gott wirklich
nicht existieren könnte
und dann kommen wir zu dem berühmten
free world of ants freie wille
verteidigung der free world of ants ist
ein versuch zu zeigen dass die erste
prämisse falsch ist bekannt was man sagt
es ja gott würde vielleicht unter
manchen umständen doch das böse erlauben
zum beispiel wenn er frei frei frei will
also
geschaffene wesen mit freier wille
schaffen wollen würde würde er erlauben
müssen dass diese geschaffene wesen dann
in einer art und weise vorgehen die böse
ist also konkret das ist ein paar will
adams oder mit die menschheit schaffen
und er weiß im voraus dass denn er der
menschheit freie wille schenkt dass die
menschheit vielleicht vielleicht schief
gehen wird und sündigen wird aber für
gottes sicht ist es wichtiger ist es
wichtiger dass freiheit zu haben als das
böse zu vermeiden
deswegen ist diese erste film ist falsch
ok oder anders gesagt die existenz
gottes ist mit sechs ist mit der
existenz böse des bösen vereinbar
ok und dass das wird sehr kompliziert
sehr schnell zb uns sehr auch sehr sehr
mit logik sehr sehr technical würde ich
sagen
zum beispiel könnte man denken okay wenn
gott allwissend ist könnte er nicht
einfach die menschen auswählen die nicht
sündigen werden und dann diese menschen
schaffen weil zum beispiel erweist er
weiß im voraus dass wenn er mich schafft
ich werde dann sündigen weil ich bin hat
so einer
und deswegen denkt er auch wenn italien
sind kreiere denn wir der sündigen
deswegen schaffe ich ihn nicht
ich schaffe jemanden der nichts liegen
wird und übrigens dass das deswegen
kommt dieser auszug trends rote kurve
also transporter graffiti heißt also die
graffiti ist sowas wie tendenz zu
sündigen und was diese philosophie zwei
dinge sagen wir das vielleicht ist es
einfach so dass alle die mögliche wesen
die gott schaffen könnte sündigen würden
in jeder möglichen welt also in jedem
möglichen welt würde jede würde jeder
freie diesen sündigen deswegen kann er
das nicht machen er kann nichts diversen
aussuchen die gut sagt die nur gut sein
werden deswegen gibt es das böse
also entitäten oder also menschen also
man kann den menschen sein
er ist allmächtig also wenn er hauste
irdische oder was schaffen wollen würde
könnte er das auch machen ja aber wenn
sie wollen können sie können sie
sozusagen von anfang an annehmen er will
menschen kriegen mit freier wille und
dann schaut er gibt es menschen die
schaffen könnte die nikon dicken werden
nein
schade also ich schaffe diese menschen
ist das ist das wahrscheinlich dass es
so ist schwer zu sagen aber das egal sie
muss nicht wahrscheinlich sein müssen
muss nur möglich sein weil wir sind hier
im rahmen des logischen problems oder
anderes beispiel waren manche gesten
sagen dann ja das hilft nichts weil das
ist nicht so als ob das böse immer von
sünde kommt zum beispiel erdbeben oder
krankheiten sind auch böse auch schlecht
gott würde sie diese bitte dieses diese
art von bösen auch abschaffen wenn er
könnte antwort war dass es satan
das ist vielleicht keine überzeugende
antwort aber das egal was eine mögliche
antwort und das reicht ok also und ich
würde sagen diese debatte ist vorbei und
die ts die besten haben gewonnen also
eine art ersten atheistischer
philosophen und übrigens fünf plus von
beruflichen philosophen sind atheisten
aber die die atheisten würden in der
regel jetzt behaupten nicht behaupten
dass dieses argument die die logische
fassung funktioniert allerdings würden
viele im weiterhin wir haben das die
sogenannte happy dance show wo steht
denn das ist das zentrale problem des
bösen wie viel man helfen
show ins deutsche übersetzen das sollte
also habe die ids es gibt wir haben viel
wie dance oder haben viele belege dafür
viele beweise nicht beweise im sinne von
wirklich beweise aber viele hinweisen
dass gott nicht existiert wir sagen okay
diese halbwissen de gott und so weiter
würde vielleicht würde der das böse
erlauben aber wahrscheinlich nicht
und vor allem was sie nicht machen würde
ist die art und menge des bösen erlauben
die wir sehen also habe ich ein bisschen
abgekürzt war das wäre lang gewesen aber
die die nehmen immer beispiele wie zum
beispiel an es gibt ein feuer im wald
und bambi stirbt und dass das helfen
keinem also niemand lernt was da raus
weil keine menschen erfahren davon
wir haben nur so ein revanchefoul
vollstedt und gott erlaubt was warum
würde das machen also es gibt kein keine
bereich keine rechtfertigung dafür und
wir sehen ständig dass solche sachen
vorkommen also babys sterben an
krankheiten vielleicht kann könnte man
sagen ja das ist damit die eltern dann
lernen
tapfer zu sein oder so was als alles
sehr sehr überzeugend und wenn wir
überlegen wie viel böse und leiden es
gibt und die art von bösen und des bösen
und leidens die es gibt sind wir
überzeugt dass wir sehr sehr gute gründe
haben nichts an gott zu glauben das ist
sozusagen die jetzige gängige fassung
des problems sie hat einen job haben
oder wiwo
trotzdem sind kann man sagen das ist
mehr oder weniger das gleiche problem
also wir sagen also ich kann nicht
beweisen dass gott nicht existiert hier
kann nur zeigen dass jeder der nachdenkt
sehen müsste das gott fast sicher nicht
nichts existiert die und die weg wie
stark dieses argument ist zeigt sich
daran dass das die beste antwort die
ersten bisher gegeben haben ist sowas
wie ja wir sind nicht gott und deswegen
verstehen wir seine gründe
wahrscheinlich nicht und wir sollen auch
nicht erwarten dass wir seine gründe
verstehen
das kommt übrigens auch syrien vor also
diese behauptung ja das ist vielleicht
alles mysteriös aber natürlich ist das
also mit unseren mitteln sie hier geben
die tasten sogar fast zu ja mit unseren
menschlichen mitteln scheint er sehr
sehr unwahrscheinlich dass gott
existiert aber glaubt trotzdem an gott
und ich sage einfach nur ja ich bin
nicht überrascht dass sich die pläne
gottes nicht verstehen kann
bitte sagen ist dass wir dass wir nichts
also wenn wir unsere app ist technische
lage betrachten und die lage gottes wäre
es die sie können sogar sagen es wäre
nicht überraschend wenn wir als
eingeschränkte menschen nachts also
nachdenken und hinter hinter sein könnte
was gott vorhat mit als das was in der
welt passiert also wir können so seien
die ein vergleich was sie geben ist wenn
du in ein dunkles zimmer gest es ist
nicht nichts überraschen dass du die
möbelstücke nicht sehen kannst ja und
wir sind wie blende menschen und die was
nicht sehen so sagen nämlich die
begründung für das leiden was in der
welt existiert es dass es nicht keine
antwort aber es ist nicht sehr
befriedigend
mein tipp dass diese debatte findet oft
in einer in dem zusammenhang statt wo
die kästen wollen beweisen nicht dass
sie recht haben sondern dass sie
vernünftig handeln wenn sie an gott
glauben also alles was sie zeigen wollen
ist dass das woran sie glauben nicht
unvernünftig ist das ist natürlich eine
sehr ein sehr niedriges ziel ist im
vergleich zu dem was sie im mittelalter
machen wollten nämlich alles mit der von
und begründen
ja also die wollen praktische nur zeigen
dass sie nicht verrückt sind
ja das ist mehr oder weniger die antwort
also die antwort ist diese überlegung
ist menschlich und gott hat eine andere
überlegung war es den macht ja so die
tester kommt noch aber mit also bisher
schon also dass hier könnten konnten und
tun dass das edith erstens sagen
natürlich verstehen wenn nicht wirst du
nur menschen
das ist mehr oder weniger die antwort
okay dass das alles hat es noch nicht
existiert vor allem dieser zusammenhang
mit ästen klatsch ist defensiv
argumentieren wir sind doch ok wird
dürfen weitermachen weil wir nicht
unvernünftig cent also diese sehr
defensive dieses sehr defensives ziel
war natürlich sehr weit weg von der von
dem ziel was man im mittelalter hatte wo
alle testen wollen also niemand hätte
gewartet zu sagen dass gott existiert
zwei davon haben das unvernünftig ist an
gott zu glauben
und dieses problem so formuliert hatte
ich würde sagen eigentlich nichts
gegeben hat es eigentlich nicht gegeben
was sie probleme verursacht hatte war er
dieses problem
das nenne ich das match physisches
problem des bösen das ist mein haus doch
jetzt habe ich erfunden also es werden
sie nicht nicht in textbücher sehen das
problem ist kommt es schon diesen nicht
hatten nicht nur mit christentum oder
islam oder judentum zu tun kommt
eigentlich zum ersten mal in platin
ismus vor
und das problem ist wolkenlos wir
behaupten dass also fangen wir mit
dieser prämisse alles entsteht durch
eine gute ursache für neu zu wissen ist
dass das gute oder das eine
für christen ist gott es gibt nur eine
ursache für alles nicht wie die
klassiker behaupten zwei ursachen einmal
böse einmal gut
nur eine ursache diese ursache ist das
eine gute dass seine prämisse zwei eine
andere prämisse das was ich auf bremse 1
habe das was durch eine gute ursache
entsteht ist auch gut so dass ein
vergleich was ich immer gws du kannst
nicht mit wasser anfangen und irgendwas
trocken machen also du hast nur diese
gute sache und du wirst irgendwie
erreichen dass das böse existiert weil
das böse existiert das sehen wir und die
frage ist woher kommt das und jetzt
haben wir die neue platonische antwort
darauf die von augustinus übernommen
würde das böse ist nichts
das böse ist nicht das nicht sein das
ist die lücke in der existenz ist es
dass das was fehlt zum beispiel
krankheit ist nichts nichts wirkliches
ist nur mangelhafte oder abwesend die
gesundheit oder schlecht das bier ist
bier ohne richtigen geschmack oder wie
auch immer
also diese wir haben sehr stark den
eindruck dass das böse genauso echt ist
und wie das gute aber das ist falsch das
böse ist gar nichts und das reine
schlechte würde das eine böse
das könnte nicht existieren weil es
werde nur ein nichts also brauchst was
gutes um was böses zu haben du glaubst
ein exotisches existierendes denn das
mangelhaft ist nur mangel werde gar
nichts
ok jetzt jetzt gehen wir zurück zu
diesen problemen
viele finden diese neue platonische
überlegung sehr hilfreich weil sie immer
noch an diese probleme denken sie fragen
sich warum können sie sagen okay auch
wenn das böse
nichts ist warum erlaubt dass gott
erlaubt gott mangel
und schwäche und das nicht sein der
innerhalb des sein aber das ist nicht
das problem
das ist das problem das ist ein problem
der kausalität nicht ein problem der
rechtfertigung und was sie erklären
wollen ist woher böse kommt aus welcher
ursache antwort haus gar keine ursache
war das nicht sein die keine ursache
braucht und dass eine sehr gute ein wort
das problem ist natürlich als antwort
auf dieses problem ist das eine gute
antwort nur wenn man es zu geben bereit
ist zu geben dass das böse wirklich nur
nichts sein okay sie meinen warum ist
eine gute gute antwort auf dieses
problem meinen sie
das ok hat gesagt hier bei die bei den
modernen problem des bösen wenn man sagt
aber das böse ist gar nichts hilft das
gar nicht weil gott warum wurde ein
guter allwissende allmächtiger gott
erlauben dass das nicht sein der
innerhalb des seins zum beispiel warum
würde er nicht schauen dass alle
menschen perfekt sind und nie mangelhaft
ok also zu sagen aber mangel ist gar
nichts ist nicht hilfreich für diese
probleme aber für dieses problem ist es
sehr hilfreich weil dieses problem ist
das problem woher das kommt also es ist
also ein wenn es um käse geht oder gehen
würde
hier ist käse im zimmer woher kommt der
käse aber wir fragen nicht woher kommen
die löcher in den käse weil weil man
keine ursache braucht um ein nicht
existentes zu verursachen weil nicht
existierende sachen mac system nichts
ursachen sind da um existierende
tatsachen oder wesens zu schaffen
das ist die lösung ok diese überlegung
ist dass die person existiert und seinen
mangel existiert nicht weil es ein
mangel ist ein nichts
übrigens dass ich hätte vielleicht auch
haben anfang sagen sollen dass wenn ich
sage das böse das beinhaltet nicht nur
moralische sünde sondern auch zum
beispiel hässlichkeit oder schmerz oder
was auch immer sind nur es nicht nur
moral moralische tatsachen gehen
was ist ihr problem
ihr problem ist sie sieht dass die welt
voller sünde ist
und leiden hat sich selbst sie hat
selbst wahnsinnig erlitten
und sie hat diese offenbarungen die
verspricht dass alles gut wird
ok erster gott sagt ihr nicht alles ist
schon gut sondern sondern alles wird gut
sein
also sie sie würde mit unbedingt sofort
an diese lösung street schließen indem
sie nicht unbedingt zu gehen muss das
ist sozusagen nichts gibt was sie
erklären müsste allerdings sagt sie
trotzdem das protein und augustinus
recht haben wo welche ist nicht klar aus
welcher quelle sie das hat aber dieses
diese theorie die ursprünglich bei
platin auftaucht dass das böse nichts
ist das kommt sehr stark in augustinus
vor und wir können aber wir können
daraus eben ein wir können davon
ausgehen
dass julian das vermittelt durch
augustinus hat okay
das problem wird dadurch gelöst dass die
sünde und sich konzentriert sich
wirklich absender nichts das böse im
allgemeinen die sünde ist da nichts und
deswegen kann man gottes versprechen
nicht dadurch widerlegen dass er was
schlechtes gemacht hat nämlich sünde
weil er die sünden nicht machen musste
also her was sie immer wieder sagt ist
gott tut alles und alles ist gut weil
gott nur das gute tun kann
sie sagt sogar dass wir das böse oder
her die sünde an sich nicht erkennen
können wir können wir haben keine
sozusagen keinen kognitiven zugang zur
sünde weil die sind ja gar nichts ist
das was dein wissen wie das problem dass
wir in der wolke des unwissens hatte
genau wie wir gott nicht begreifen
können so sind auch nichts diesen beiden
ich zu gott weil er zu erhaben es zu
ende war es gar nix ist und deswegen
erkennen wir senden
nur durch das leiden leiden ist die
wirkung wurde dass es die erscheinung
des könnte lauten übrigens das ist so
weit wie ich weiß eine neue idee die sie
in diese debatte einbringt
das kann leiden nicht einfach eine art
des bösen ist sondern eine erscheinung
des bösen das ist sehr interessant denke
ich trotzdem fragt sie sich wie es sein
kann und dass sünde überhaupt in die in
die geschichte der menschheit
reingekommen ist also wie uhr sonde
geschehen ist und hier ist sie ein
bisschen näher an diesem problem also
warum gott sünde erlauben würde
sie hat sozusagen die das nette fisch
ist das problem gelöst und jetzt
betrachtet sie ob sie dieses problem
lösen kann also warum gott sünde
erlauben würde
und hier aber sie kommt näher dran
natürlich formel ist sie das nicht so
aber sie sie fragt sich woher woher
dieses nichts kommt sozusagen das was
sie wollten dass das jemand erklärt ok
wenn das ein nichts ist warum ist das
nicht erlaubt und was sie sagt ist sehr
interessant
sie kann nichts sagen das was wir
wahrscheinlich erwarten denken würden
nämlich die menschheit könnte dies an
die vermeiden
wir tun das aber nichts weil das wäre
perla guinness muss also seine das ist
eine häresie also wenn man behauptet
dass menschen in ist dass sie aus ihren
eigenen mitteln gut sein können dann
würden sie keine gnade brauchen und dann
stürzen wir gegen avastin ische
orthodoxie deswegen gibt sie zu dass wir
dass wir immer sündigen müssen
und das kommt aus russland also das ist
alles sehr hot dogs und traditionsgemäß
als sehr aggressiv
sie bringt eine sehr schöne analogie und
das zu erklären
sie sagt dass die menschheit wie ein
diener ist der die wünsche seines herrn
aus erfüllen will und läuft eifrig weg
von dem herrn um seine wünsche zu
erfüllen
fällt in einen graben und leidet
fürchterlich
das ist unsere unsere jetzige zustand
natürlich dann kommt ja her am ende und
sagt oh du du wolltest mir ein gutes tun
und dass du geld hast das war nicht
seine schuld also du hast gelitten
gelitten
ich belohne dich für dein leiden was
hier interessant ist ist dass man sieht
wieder wie optimistisch sie ist dieser
vergleich kommt auch in hans albers vor
im elften jahrhundert und dort sagt an
sein muss dass der däne ist ein böser
diener der gegen die welle des herrn
agiert sie sagt genau das gegenteil sagt
der däne ist ein guter diener aber ist
beschränkt und begeht fehler einfach
weil der diener nicht so gut ist wieder
her
also er per meinte es gut habe irrt sich
weil das einfach zu erwarten ist von den
diener weil er nicht so gut ist wieder
her fahren alles anders gesagt sündigen
wir immer aus guten absicht laut ihr
weil wir einfach so schwach sind und
dann sagt sie was anderes was sehr
interessant ist die wir haben zwei
aspekten in der seele sind nettes zwei
villen eine gute wille und eine
schlechte rolle
und was wirklich sehr sehr interessant
ist und das ist fast ketzerisch was sie
sagt mir das klingt wie die pelle pelle
ergebnis muss sie sagt dann die gute
welle ist eine welle die wm behalten und
mit dieser wille ist immer mit gott
vereint das ist diese dieses thema der
vereinigung mit gott die wir bei
margareta und so weiter hatten und wir
sind sozusagen per netz mit gott vereins
sie sagt immer mit gott in jeder serie
die gerettet wird gibt es eine göttliche
wille diniz ende gehen wird
leider haben wir eine zweite welle die
tierische will oder schlecht wie nie
mit dieser welle sündigen wir immer also
wir sind gerissen in 2 und uns unsere
aufgabe ist die die schwächere
schlechtere tierische welle zu
mindestens im rahmen zu halten und zu
schwächen deswegen askese und diese
dieses leben das sie geführt hat aber
gute nachricht wir haben auch diese gute
welle und durch diese welle werden wir
alle gerettet und am ende mit gott
vereins oder vielleicht doch nicht
und hier kommt ein sehr keine sehr
spannendes thema in dem werk vor
sie hat das problem dass sie aus der
kirchlichen autorität weiß dass manche
sehen doch verdammt werden nun in die
hölle geschickt werden und dann hat auf
einer seite hat sie plötzlich die kirche
auf andere seite hat sie selber von gott
direkt unmittelbar gehört dass alles gut
wird
wer hat recht die kirche oder gott und
dann sagt sie ja wahrscheinlich die
kirche weil ich will nicht gegen die
kirche stoßen aber ich verstehe nicht
ganz wie so manche sehen doch verdammt
werden müssen und das ist rätselhaft
also man man könnte also man natürlich
dazu zu denken was sie eigentlich denkt
ist dass alle gerettet werden weil sie
so optimistisch denkt aber sie will das
nicht offen sagen weil das nicht erlaubt
ist
es wäre meine vermutung persönlich jetzt
also es ist wirklich bald alles sehr
innovativ und wird neu in der stadt
füssen die theologie
deswegen wird sie einmal so geschätzt
als ein sehr großer denker und ich würde
natürlich ist das sehr theologisch also
hat natur sondern es zu tun und so
weiter aber klar dass sie werden
wahrscheinlich zu geben sie sind
wahrscheinlich bereits in suhl zu geben
dass das finde ich sehr interessant ist
interessanter vergleich was hat sie mit
margareta gemeinsam und was nicht
erstens können wir den raum von letzter
woche
margareta portals werke oder gewerk
meine ich ein buch würde ins englische
übersetzt war julian wahrscheinlich
nicht bekannt weil die übersetzungen zu
spät kommt aber interessanterweise
bewegt sich dieses buch in den gleichen
kreisen von unter kapuziner wie julians
buch allerdings war julian bekannt als
autor habe das buch von margaretha war
wie ich gesagt habe immer anonym
verbreitet
also erstens haben wir es gibt eine
saison eine englische margareta die
gleichzeitig mit julian dann einfluss im
15 jahrhundert ausübt also da ist es das
ist interessant zweitens ist margarete
und das ist noch ein schönes beispiel
davon dass wir nicht all die frauen auf
einem haufen tun sollen die männer
artmann den haufen juliana ist sehr
asketisch und margareta nicht können sie
sich vielleicht daran erinnern dass
margareta keine zeit dafür hatte wenn
sie sagt wir sich als befreites leben
jenseits der tugend was sie hier unter
tugend versteht ist hauptsächlich als
käse sie ist sehr kritisch gegenüber
askese sogar kritischer als das buch des
unwissens aber es ähnlich eckel
ähnlicher hand immer die die wolke des
unwissens margareta ins leere es ähnlich
wie die wie die lehre dass der wolke des
unwissens hier haben wir die tugend dann
gehen wir weiter hinaus und margareta
und und syriens sind mehr oder weniger
hier vielleicht und dann von julias hier
als gäbe es hier ist katharina von siena
julien
hier ist sind wolke des unwissens und
margareta als die die sind praktisch
jenseits von allem jenes von
körperlichen visionen denken nur an
liebe gott das ist wird sehr kommt
kontemplativ viele leute des unwissens
selber sagt und mit dieser mit diesem
tendenz gemäss ist die tatsache dass
julian immer sehr gute sachen über 40
die tour wird sagt das ist betont immer
wieder dass die tugend der richtige weg
ist die gute welle zu stärken und durch
die gute würde zu leben also es gibt
keine ist nicht die rede ist nichts
davon dass man die tugend irgendwie
überspringen soll oder dass man jenseits
der tugend dann sich entwickeln soll wie
in margareten also interessanterweise
ist julian in dieser hinsicht viel
konservativer als margareta obwohl sie
in anderen hinsichten viel innovativer
ist also jeder theologie ist super
innovativ habe ihre tugend lehre ist
sehr traditionell
interessanterweise und vielleicht das
offensichtlichste ist das margareta fast
scheint der sie fast absichtlich
versucht hatte die kirche ist zu
irritieren und vielleicht sogar
beleidigen zum beispiel wo sie sagt es
gibt die niedrige kirche oder die die
kinderkirche und die große kirche ist
mitglied der großen kirche und die
weltliche kirche ist die mit der kirche
während julian super vorsichtig ist
immer zu sagen okay ich weiß dass meine
lehrer jetzt in eine gefährliche
richtung kommt und deswegen weil ich
sofort anerkennen dass die kirche recht
hat und nicht dagegen stoßen ist es
überhaupt nicht die persönlichkeit die
wir bei margareta finden
deswegen war
heldenhafte lernen gefeiert werden
margareta umgebracht worden worden ist
das macht schon einen unterschied man
nächste woche werden wir katharina van
sienna betrachten die auch als sehr
bewundert würde in ihrem leben und sehr
aber jetzt vielleicht zu tage sehr
problematisch ist alles denken vor allem
weil sie diese asketische tendenz in der
metall- günstig super weit gebracht hat
uns sogar gestalt an gestorben ist